[Music]
elon musk is the billionaire ceo of
spacex and tesla
and was ranked by forbes magazine as
number 21 on their list of the world's
most
powerful people he went from being
raised by his abusive father in the
suburbs of south africa
to now being the 20th richest person in
the world with a net worth of
27.9 billion dollars and today we're
going to learn his best advice on why
you must be
persistent
rise and shine it's espresso time
[Music]
i wake up every morning
hey it's evan carmichael and every
morning i give you a shot of espresso to
help you believe in yourself more and
start your day with confidence
so good morning i believe in you and
let's do this
elon musk tell us how to be persistent
when i started the first uh internet
companies up to um
with my brother and another person um a
great curry
the uh it wasn't really with the thought
of being wealthy
you know we're going against being
wealthy but um
we'll get back to that later but it's
just it was just from the standpoint
i've been wanting to be part of the
internet and
uh i i figured if we could make enough
money to
just get by would be they'll be okay um
and when we started off
uh we we literally only had like one
computer
and so it would be our web server during
the day and i'd code at night
um and we we just got a a small office
um uh in palo alto back when rent was
not
insane um and uh
it cost us like 450 a month it was
cheaper than an apartment so we actually
just slept in the office
and then and then shower at the ymca at
page mill el camino
so we'd walk over there and and shower
and uh
and that was um actually i think uh
that was when i we first i first met you
by the way um
and uh so i don't know how many people
probably know many people know this but
uh
uh we actually pitched uh steve in like
january 96
on uh the zip2 business plan uh and
actually i thought she was
actually one of the most up to speed on
on what actually was in our business
plan most most
people we met did not actually read our
business plan um
in fact a lot of people a lot of venture
capitalists at the time didn't even
know what the internet was or they've
never used they've never used they're
shorter than the things
we still do yeah right yeah i'm talking
like you know
sort of well-known people on sand hill i
was like wow okay um
but at the time nobody made any any
money on the internet so i guess
that's um you know there wasn't really
clear evidence that there was was a
business
if you've got a big dream people are
always going to tell you that you are
nuts some of them won't believe in you
because they
love you and they're afraid for you
others are going to put you down because
they hate their own lives and now nobody
around them can have success at all
but if you want to win if you want to
take that crazy idea and make it happen
you're going to have to believe in
yourself when nobody else does
until it happens for you i look at my
story and everything that's happened for
me
on youtube and in my business and career
and a lot of it has just been patience
and persistence
it's been showing up every day making
content grinding it out
and slowly by slowly by solo you start
getting some wins i look at even
starting on youtube guys 11 years ago my
first video
youtube was not an educational platform
you can go back and watch that first
video it's still there it's
me talking about walt disney's story go
check it out
it's embarrassing i feel super awkward
looking at that
backwards but nobody was making
content that was more than five minutes
nobody was making educational content
nobody was making videos where you can
learn something youtube was
a totally different platform at the time
just basically filled with memes
and so here i was making this content
just because i thought it might help
maybe it was a little bit stupid to be
honest maybe i should have been
somewhere else but i'm a visual learner
and i want to be on a visual platform
and youtube seemed to be the only place
to host video content at the time
eventually youtube kind of cut up not
that i was
visionary or some pioneer or leader not
with intention at least
but youtube became a place where you
could go to learn things a lot of people
the first place they go to now is
youtube they go how do i learn how to
xyz
youtube for a lot of people is the
number one place that they go to it's a
fantastic place for educational content
now
but it wasn't 11 years ago when i
started and so it's just because i stuck
around
because i believed in it i thought it
was helpful maybe not for the planet the
world but
it's helpful for a couple of people who
are watching pieces of video i was
making
and sending in comments i think about
the relationships i've built with people
over time i think about you know tony
robbins was the first person we
did a profile on that he then featured
it on his own youtube channel as well
and linked to it
and then we tried to line up an
interview for him to be on my channel
and he said
yes and then last minute he had
something else happen
and he had to cancel it so i said no
problem let's let's figure out another
time to make it happen
tony welcome aboard man thanks evan
great to be with you
and it took two years it took two years
to make it happen
i didn't even realize it took that long
when i look at my first email sequence
with them
that set up the meeting to then when i
actually had it happen was two years in
between
and what am i doing in those two years
i'm still making videos i'm still
profiling tony i'm still reaching out to
his team
i'm still providing value to them and
pushing them and helping them with their
youtube presence
always constantly consistently for two
years and then the tony robbins
interview happens
and that's led to other opportunities
and more people want to have me come on
and speak on their stage and make videos
on them and help them with their youtube
channels and
everything has started to spiral up but
it's because of just staying patient and
staying consistent and i still have the
mentality of
when i started my channel nobody
commented on my videos right my mom
was my first comment my older sister was
my second comment and then some random
dude was my third comment
and and in a year that first video only
had those three comments
i appreciate you guys for watching i
appreciate everybody
that that comes and consumes the content
i still
relate more to that startup creator
startup entrepreneur more than having
had all the success
but what makes me different it's not
that i'm more talented than people i
remember being sad when i passed
eric thomas on youtube and tony robbins
on youtube when my channel was bigger
than theirs because i feel like they had
a lot more talent than me
and it's part of my mission to try to
get
get people who have a strong voice to
share more content to get it up there
because i think if i have you know 2
million subscribers on my main channel
then tony robbins should have
should have 20 should have 200 million
like it should be a much crazier number
and so i was sad when i passed some of
them on youtube why
how it's because i made six thousand
plus videos it's because
every day i'm making vid i can't
remember the last day we didn't post a
single video
we're posting now i don't know four or
five videos a day
across our channels maybe more six i'm
trying to think now we've got 12
channels
it's just crazy number of content and
now i've got a team and they help me and
yes it's super valuable but
i make videos when i'm sick today is my
birthday
i'm recording this on may 20th that's my
birthday i just turned 40 years old
uh and people are saying hey what are
you taking the day off
no i'm making videos this is this is
what i love doing
i broke my neck i'm making videos on my
birthday i'm breaking videos
breaking videos making videos i lose my
voice i'm sick i'm still making videos
i remember i lost my voice i couldn't
talk at all and so i would hold up
signs and have the words on the sign for
you guys to read we still made videos
videos have to go up and so i think
if you study my journey it's one much
more of just persistency
and following through and not giving up
and continuing to
to make and to produce and to create
even though most things don't work
and even though i didn't have the
natural talent i'm introverted
i'm shy i'm awkward um it's taken a lot
of practice just to get to this point
and it can be super frustrating to see
other people just get in front of the
camera and crush it
who are who are you at your level or
even ahead and it's like how many videos
you made i don't know five
why are you kidding me right
but you play the hanes that you were
dealt
you mean not could be able to control
whether you're naturally introverted or
extroverted or have
circumstances growing up right you can't
control that but you can always control
your effort
you can always control how persistent
you are you can always control how you
show up
every single day and where are the
moments that you let yourself down that
you let yourself off the hook that you
let yourself not make
not post not follow through how often is
it
i'm making videos on my birthday not
because of some streak
or some commitment but because this is
what i want to do guys
this is what fills me up and when you
find the thing that makes you
feel up that you know is providing value
and service
even in a small way right now having the
persistence
to stay on it when everyone thinks
you're nuts having the belief in
yourself
to stay on it when everybody thinks
you're crazy that's what makes a
difference
between the people who you look up to as
heroes and the people who you've never
heard of because they quit
and they fell back to a life that was
less than what they could have been
now i've got a three-step process that
you can use to stay persistent when the
doubt is creeping into your mind but
before that if you want to have
unstoppable confidence and learn from
billionaires check out my 254 series
where every day
for 254 days i will help you build the
habit
of confidence for free the links to join
are in the description below there are
just times when
something is important enough that you
believe it enough that
you you do it in spite of fear if you
have a great product lots of people will
buy it
and then the company will be successful
that that ended up being worse than if
we had designed a car from
from the beginning okay my three-step
process to stay persistent to stay
consistent to have the belief in
yourself
when everyone thinks you're crazy here
we go step number one is use the nose
as fuel and i add this in not because i
use it but because i know it works for a
lot of other people and
and i'm channeling tom bill you right
now this is one of the things that tom
does
that's he credits to having his success
if you know tom impact theory
built a billion dollar business with
with quest and now has his awesome
youtube channel
he has a list he has a list of all the
people who doubted him
who didn't believe in him and whenever
he feels like he really needs that extra
motivation
he goes to that dark place and looks at
that list and say all these people did
not believe in me i'm gonna show them
wrong
i don't do that i don't get a lot of
power strength for myself
of being in the dark side of proving
somebody wrong
but i think it can be very beneficial
for people
and a lot of people do talk about it so
i wanted to
at least give that to you as an option
use those no's as fuel
use that your mom telling you that you
suck and you can't make it
maybe she doesn't say that you suck but
that you can't make it using
your friends or haters online saying
that you're never going to do it using
that as fuel to say i'm going to show
you and prove you wrong
i just think the danger is if you live
in there for too long if you're only
fueled for the dark side it consumes you
if you're only doing something to prove
somebody wrong you're never going to
stay consistent persistent enough
because it's not a good enough reason
at the core of doing the thing has to be
you love doing the thing you want to
serve right
you're built to serve you want to serve
you want to help you want to help
right but if you have to channel the
dark side
every now and then use those noses fuel
to help you get forward then go for it
give it a shot
step number two is remember your why and
this is what i lean on a lot more i
remember why i do what i do i remember
the 19 year old evan who was struggling
who couldn't pay anything who felt
worthless incompetent
hopeless embarrassed ashamed showing up
every day working his face off and not
getting any results and just feeling
like a total loser
that's what i remember that's what i
channel that's my why because there's a
lot of people who are like that
right now they're struggling who are
good people who have a big mission who
have a big heart who want to serve and
help
and and they're struggling and they
don't know how to do it and nobody
believes in them and so i want to be
that guy i want to i want to try to help
and and maybe
a video like this hits five people and
it touches them in a meaningful way and
maybe it hits five million
but knowing that at least it's helping
somebody remembering who i used to be
and knowing that there's so many people
who are like that and i'm trying and
punching i'm grinding every day to try
to reach more of those people in
different ways
that fuels me to keep going much more
than going to the dark side at least for
me
remembering your why and who you used to
be and knowing that you are built to
serve and have to chase it down with
every
ounce of your being and step number
three is focus on progress
when you focus on progress instead of
the end result
that's where i think you can keep your
motivation and keep your belief
when i first started making my videos i
wasn't getting any results
right nobody was watching nobody was
commenting i felt
like a loser right nobody cares it's not
happening
i'm not getting the results understand
that you very rarely ever get results at
the beginning
if you focus on just getting the results
at the beginning you're likely going to
get too discouraged and quit
it's not that the results aren't
important it's just people have a
too short an attention span and when you
focus on the result at the beginning it
is too discouraging and you do give up
instead you focus on the progress are
you getting better are you learning was
your video
better than last time did you show up
with more energy than last time did you
have
better points than you did last time was
that sales call you did
better than the one last time was your
next test better than it was yesterday
right are you getting better
because if you can say i'm getting
better if you if you're making videos
and you look back
a week later a month later and say man i
still suck but i'm better than i was
a week ago a month ago and you can focus
on the progress
at least for me it really helps fuel my
motivation my belief in myself that hey
if i made that growth from here to here
then i can make more growth from here to
here and at the beginning
here's the thing at the beginning the
growth is pretty fast
when you're learning something from from
scratch at the beginning you actually
learn very quickly
it's at the end that it gets harder for
me
right now to keep getting better is
harder i don't see as big a return
on my on my progress as evan carmichael
growth
from last week to this week from last
month to this month how much better am i
on camera
from last month to this month not that
much
it requires even more effort and even
more mentorship and even more practice
and training to get better as
when you're close to the top at the
beginning
you can learn really quickly and there's
a lot of progress the flip side for me
now is lots of results
right when you start actually getting
good that's when the results kick
in so then you can start focusing on the
results so hey is this working or not is
this video doing better than the last
one or not because you start getting
some data and results to work with
so at the beginning you're focusing on
the progress am i getting better am i
improving and am i learning is it better
than i was last week
and then as that starts to taper off you
might get frustrated with your progress
but good news
you're going to start seeing results
come in and that'll keep you motivated
to keep going as well
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that
question of the day i want to know what
are you proud of your growth
from the past month think about who you
were a year
a month ago and where you are now and
what's the thing that you are the most
proud of for how you've grown over that
month let me know put in the comments
below
and if you made it this far in a video
you're still here watching and you
promise you commit that you're gonna do
something about it we take action here
in believe nation
you're promising to take action in your
life today based off of what you learned
here in this video
i want to celebrate you give me a
hashtag believe down the comments as
well
i moved in one of my buddies from
indiana said you got to come to dallas
and i'm like i'm there
you know my car would only get so far i
had a fiat x19 with a hole in the
floorboard that
guzzled oil every 60 miles and i went
down there and this place called the
village it's the world was the world's
largest apartment complex
we had six guys in a three-bedroom
apartment i didn't have my own room i
didn't have my own drawer i didn't have
my closet
i had a pile and i had one ratty towel
that i stole from
motel 6. and that was it and so
i was looking for my career got a job at
the software store
and i was you know i was didn't have a
tech background so i was teaching myself
all this
because the way i look at tech is
somebody invents it
and everybody else is tied for second
place and the ability to learn it
and if if i work harder and faster
to really dive in if it means reading
the manual you know
just diving in then i can get a head
start
i was 24. and so sleeping on the floor
working in a software company
you know learning learning learning
learning learning getting better at what
i was doing
and then one day because i was dying to
get out of that rat hole that i lived in
um i had a chance to go out and close
the sale
for that would he got me a fifteen
hundred dollar commission and so i went
to my boss his name is michael
and i said boss one of my
responsibilities was to sweep the floor
wipe down the windows and open the door
to open the store i got the sale you got
to let me close the sale
he goes no you got to be in here to open
the store and i'm like
michael i mean no so i made the
executive decision
to go out pick up the check thinking if
i had this guy a fifteen thousand dollar
check
of course he's going to change his mind
fired me on the spot
and so here i was living in a use my
french you know just this ratty place
with a
motel six towel sorry motel six um
and and really didn't know how i was
going to get out but
i went to i decided okay i'm a lousy
employee i went to
um one of the companies that i've been
talking to architectural lighting
and i said look um i need 500 to be able
to buy the software you want and i
promise you
that even if it doesn't work i will wash
your car you know i will walk your dog
i don't care what it is i will do
whatever it takes to make it up to you
and they gave me the 500 and that
allowed me to create micro solutions
and you know six months later i was out
of the rat hole and
my company turned into a real company
and that's the one i sold um for six
million dollars when i was 29 30 years
old
if you want more inspiration morning
videos they're not on this channel
anymore i have a dedicated channel just
for it
it's right there next to me go click it
there continue to believe
and i'll see you there